من رام الله الكاتب والباحث السياسي ساري
عرابي نرحب بك استاذ ساري في تقديرك ما
الذي سيرج كفه هذا الطرف او ذاك بالنظر
لهذه الخلافات الواضحه بسبب صفقه تبادل
محتمله او او هدنه ربما قادمه بمعنى اخر
هل من الممكن ان يرضخ نتنياهو في نهايه
المطاف يعني هناك موقفان متنازع داخل
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه هناك مو الصهيونيه
الدينيه التي لا تقيم ادنى اي وزن للاسرى
الاسرائيليين لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه
داخل قطاع غزه ايه احزاب الصهيونيه
الدينيه تبدو انها الاقوى حتى هذه اللحظه
باعتبار انها الحليف الاكثر موثوقيه
بالنسبه لبنيامين نتنياهو ولكنها في الوقت
نفسه الحليف الاكثر قدره على ابتزاز
بنيامين نتنياهو ودفع بنيامين نتنياهو نحو
خيارات سياسيه وعسكريه وامنيه قد يراها
الموقف الاخر المقابل انها تشكل خطرا
استراتيجيا على مصلحه الكيان الاسرائيلي
ومن ثم هذا ما بينته نجوان من خلال نقل
بعض السجلات التي ارت داخل المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه ما بين افي دختر الذي اتهم
اسمه تريتش بانه لا يملك خبره عسكريه ومن
ثم هو لا يستطيع ان يقدر رايا صحيحا فيما
يتعلق بالحرب العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين
داخل قطاع غزه وفي سياقها موضوع الاسر على
وجه التحديد رد بن كثير على افد اختار
بانه كثيرا ما سمع في هذه الغرفه اراء ذات
خبره عسكريه وكانت تقول دائما ان حركه
حماس حركه مرجوعه ولكن تبين تماما ان
اصحاب الخبره العسكريه هم الذين لا لكون
الراي الصحيح والراي الصائب ومن ثم نحن
نتحدث عن خلاف حقيقي على هذا المستوى لكن
حتى هذه اللحظه هذا الخلاف الحقيقي هو
الذي يطيل امد هذه الحرب ويرضخ بن يمين
نتنياهو ما يزال حتى هذه اللحظه للراي
الاكثر تطرفا واكثر تعنتا وان كان على
المستوى الاستراتيجي هو الراي الاكثر
خطوره على الكياد الاسرائيلي ما الذي قد
يكثر في ضوء ميله كما كما ذكرت للراي
الاكثر تطرفا والاكثر يمينيه في حكومته
مستقبل حكومه الطوارئ في في ضوء كل ما
ذكرت تماما الذي يكسر قد يكسر من شوكه
احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه على هذا الصعيد
ان كان بنيامين نتنياهو بالفعل قابل للبحث
عن شبكه امان اخرى غير احزاب الصهيونيه
الدينيه لبيد عرض شيئا من هذا القبيل
جانتس قد يعرض شيئا من هذا القبيل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدفع بهذا
الاتجاه جنرالات الجيش بعضهم اصلا في مجلس
الحرب مثل ايزنكوت بعض جنرالات الجيش
الاحتياط ايضا يدفعون بمثل هذا الاتجاه
الضغط داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي الذي يتصاعد
لاعطاء اولويه اكبر لملف الاسرى
الاسرائيليين لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه
يضغط بهذا الاتجاه هذه الاعتبارات كلها
وسواها من شان ذلك الحقيقه ان يكسر من
شوكه الصهيونيه الدينيه ايضا بنيامين
نتنياهو في الحقيقه يخشى تماما بما تتفضلي
بالاشاره اليه من خروج جانتس من مجلس
الحرب ومن انفراط حكومه الطوارئ في حال لو
تبين ان بنيامين نتنياهو يقدم حساباته
السياسيه الضيقه ويقدم مخاوفه المستقبليه
على المصلحه الكليه للكيان الاسرائيلي
بنيمين نتنياهو بقدر ما يحرص على ان يتوفر
على اكبر شبكه امان ممكنه من خلال الاحزاب
الصهيونيه ال دينيه ولكنه ايضا يريد ان
يقول للمجتمع الاسرائيلي انه يود وحده
وطنيه وانه يتبنى موقفا وطنيا ولا يتبنى
موقفا شخصيا وهو يتسلح بذلك ويتغطى بذلك
من خلال وجود جانتس وبالتالي فكره جانتس
او بعض الشخصيات المحسوبه على جيتس التي
تستعجله للخروج اذا ما استمر هذا الخلاف
او طال امده على الاقل في هذه المرحله مدى
تاثيره على اي صفقه محتمله في هذه
المرحله الحقيقه على المدى القريب من
الواضح تماما ان مثل هذا الخلاف حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يسير باتجاه ايجابي تجاه
المقترحات والصفقات المقدمه حتى هذه
اللحظه وان كان بامكاننا ان نقول ان
استمرار الحرب بهذا الشكل واعطاء الاولويه
للحرب على حساب الاسرى الاسرائيليين داخل
قطاع غزه ويعارض موقف المؤسسه الامنيه حتى
هذه اللحظه فيما يبدو في ظاهر الامر
باعتبار ان الرئيس المساد هو احد
المشاركين اصلا في صياغه المقترح ال الذي
انبثق عن مباحثات باريس ومن ثم نحن نتحدث
ليس فقط عن بنيامين نتنياهو نتحدث عن
مؤسسه راسخه وعميقه داخل الكيان
الاسرائيلي في الحقيقه تخالف توجه بنيمين
نتنياهو وتخالف توجه المؤسسه الدينيه على
صعيد هذا الصراع من الصعب حتى هذه اللحظه
ان نحكم ما هو الموقف الذي قد يتغلب في
نهايه الامر لكن على المستوى القريب تبدو
هذه الخلافات مؤشرا على صعوبه ان يتفق
الكيان الاسرائيلي على صفقه لا اقول صفقه
معقوله بالنسبه للفلسطينيين بل حتى صفقه
معقوله بالنسبه لاوسط داخل المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
الكاتب والباحث السياسي ساري عرابي